[Music]
we trust experts but that doesn't always
work out especially in the field of
education policy back in 2001 Congress
passed the No Child Left Behind Act set
the ambitious goal that a hundred
percent of our nation's students would
be reading and doing math will
grade-level by 2014
didn't work out we didn't even come
close but along the way we actually did
some real harm schools got over focused
on testing kids got caught up in
drilling kill assignments and parents
got concerned that schools forgot a lot
of what matters for a kid's education or
take the Obama administration's
School Improvement Grants program seven
billion dollars later a 2017 federal
evaluation found that the program made
no difference for kids in participating
schools expertise has a role to play but
experts only know a little bit about
what actually goes on in complicated
schools and among the complexities of
education policy that's why you do well
to take advice from any of us experts
with more than a few grains of sorrow to
learn more about my take on school
reform check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like a EEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds